the you know the speaker uh worst fear
is like disappoint of full room as the
absolute worst possible so we've had um
yesterday this um nice uh you know these
nice puzzlers with uh wbe interview
questions for C++ programmers and God I
wouldn't have made that job I would have
landed that thing at all um but I assume
one of the qu interview questions that
you would be able to answer seeing would
be U Implement a binary search for me
please can you do this could you sit
down and Implement a under interview
pressure binary
search I could try okay that's that's an
excellent answer so we're going to talk
about uh today about binary search and
uh no worries if you forgot the
Integrity of it we're going to recap
them and uh it is with great uh
trepidation uh that uh I must say that
uh I think there is one rough Edge in
binary search even though we have
literally used it for Millennia uh in
binary search that uh needs to be
improved with that let's proceed with uh
my unwilling Obsession my reluctant
Fascination my careless craziness which
is improve on concer I didn't sign up
for that I didn't want to do it it just
so happened so uh back in
2014 uh I defined two algorithms for
string to numeric conversion and they're
Today part of uh metal F library but
they're not part of the standard uh
Library implementations as far as I know
they're quite a few quite a bit faster
than the the the classics uh 2017 I
published a paper in an uh algorithms
conference uh fast deterministic
selection in which I showed that um
an algorithm can be written that does a
lot better than uh GCC and clanks uh
implementations of an element uh but
apparently nobody took notice 2019 I uh
discussed a faster STD make Heap quite a
bit faster than the originally
implemented in the um the three major
implementations of STL I discussed in
CBB 2019 talk nobody
noticed somehow I'm starting to think
you know whose arm should I twist here
to uh get people's attention then the
pandemic came which has no no link to
anything at all but I had to fill those
things 2023 September which is today
we're going to discuss about the better
binary search so that's you know that is
the the history of uh where how we got
here um the history of binary search
itself is a lot more interesting and it
originates I look like you know what was
the first binary search ever described
and it turns out uh it has quite a long
history uh all the way from you know the
BC era when they counted backwards I
mean come on you you're born like year
minus 400 how did you know right yeah I
me born in year minus 5 400 I'm going to
live until like 300 uh 35 and you know
that's going to be my life between these
two negatives this is weird I have no
idea how those people did the calendar
thing that was a joke J to the people in
the back there okay so uh Archimedes is
known to have used the meth of
dichotomus and that is a very uh close
cousin of um binary search essentially
in philosophy you you're look you're
looking at dividing sets into uh two and
Archimedes figured out the better the
equal you know the better closeing size
the two sets are the better right so you
want to divide sets into two roughly
equal uh parts so then you can dispense
with one half and then focus on the
other half and repeat that method a
number of times uh ukl uh did the same
with a number of geometrical and
mathematical proofs uh Socrates Plato
Aristotle the cart uh the cart like
dichotomy and the cart were very kind of
um one item those the C applied method
of dichotomy everywhere For Better or
Worse um and then in math uh per se sort
of the first uh clear note of uh
bsection was by balzano in the 1800s and
then it became more formalized in uh in
the 20th century binary search the first
mention of binary search was in one of
the jatakas who knows what the jataka is
all right for those of you who are not
experts in Buddhist
religion I'm not but I have Google and I
I have the advantage of like knowing you
searching before you guys right so
essentially uh you know in one of the
the stories about um uh you know the
previous lives of Buddha there was a
description of binary search it was you
know you have these families and you
divide them in two and you divide the
remaining families into two and so on
until you get to I don't know one guy
and you kill him or I don't know what
happened then so um uh but it's kind of
funny that in
1946 Okay this not working it's kind of
1946 uh mle published an actual
implementation of binary search for
computers so it was the first um Advent
of an actual binary search algorithm
that was exactly meant for computer
programming and the funny thing is it
only worked if n the number of element
search was exactly two to the power of n
minus one did not work for any other
size which is kind of funny I mean you
know come on I mean you got to run for
other sizes as well it turns out if the
number of elements search is 2 to the^
of n minus one if you have two you get
the^ nus one minus one and then that
makes the whole analysis very easy but
if it's not they didn't know what to do
and if you're like me you're thinking
hey you know what I wish I would travel
back in time to you're like
1946 and I would show those nink poops
how it's done I mean come on you do the
approximate know divide by two and you
get like you know you get like just a
bit of the median and uh you move on and
uh you you're going to amaze everybody
it's going to like oh my god oh did they
come back from the future right so the
part of the algorithm is you eliminate
so this kind of the interesting tidbit
you eliminate as many elements as
possible don't focus on finding
something as you would do in a linear
search like is this the guy no is this
the guy no is this the guy no so you
focus on actually collapsing the search
range you're looking at collapsing the
set of elements you look at and that's
the of the
algorithm now do I care we're not going
to improve binary search by 2x not going
to improve it by a not of magnitude we
may improve it by a couple of
comparisons don't forget there are very
few comparisons to start with because
binary search is in log 2 N which means
if you look at 1 million elements how
many comparisons are relable to
do who said
20 what
what who 1 million elements how many
comparisons do you do log to log to of 1
million all right folks important
numbers in Computing powers of two two
to the power of 10 1,000 to the power of
20 1 million right
roughly right but you know we'll do
approximation so you know 1 million
elements you're looking at 20
comparisons or about right so if you
save if you shove off one or two of
those 20 comparisons you're going to get
you know uh 5 to 10% improvements on an
algorithm that's been like there for 2
4,000 years I mean that you know I I
would sign up for that right I'd be
happy to do
that now um look at this however because
some people may be at you know computers
are fast enough and you know all those
good things but come on we already are
the goddamn scrooges of computer science
and
engineering we are the people who don't
Che Che bonds AIS on Vector where the
people who don't do uh null check on STD
share pointer and you know all smart
pointers in the standard we are the
people who Define the STD optional of
which only purpose is to be like
optional but then we don't check that
it's
there the irony of this and the fact
that the people in the standard did not
figure out the Aron of this which makes
it squared
baffles
me right consider this let's let's
define a type that is going to be safe
to optionally store something in there
it may be there it may be
not okay are we there are with me so the
whole purpose of the type is to be an
optional presence of
something and then they said how do we
access that thing oh I know let's define
an operator
Arrow which by itself is kind of a bit I
mean come on that's not a pointer but
let's uh let's roll with the punches as
they say right so then we say okay so
I'm going to Define this awesome operate
operator Arrow that's going to give me
the optional value for which I built
this entire
facility and then you know I'm not going
to check that I assume it's
there I assume it's
there okay
so who who uses C++ in this
room okay we are those
people okay we are the problem
okay now fine optional and the list goes
on and the price we pay is steep uh it's
it's kind of a problem that we we uh we
um we are so happy about the last bit of
efficiency that can't be even
demonstrated because come on I mean
let's face it the the null check in a
smart pointer
is going to have a 100% success rate so
it's a very easily predictable test
right you know the branch predictor so
there's a branch there are multiple
branch predictors in in uh in today's uh
Computing units
and the way Branch predictor works is if
you don't take a specific side of the
branch it's just going to predict and
next time it's going to do the same so
for a null pointer check that Branch
predictor is going to have literally
100% success rate you know I know that
because the time you know the one time
is going to not succeed the whole
application is going to
fail right so it's like you know it it's
like you know one of those jobs like I'm
you know I'm a mountain climber or I'm
like a you know one of those people who
work with bombs like the bomb diffuser
or whatever they call them they can't
make one mistake in their career and
then you're done so that's that test
right I know it's a little dark for you
sorry okay
so so I do care about saving those
couple of comparisons from out of 20 yes
I do care and you care too even if you
kind of don't know it yet right so today
we're going to look at no risk
performance improvements for STD binary
search and friends and let's see how we
can do
that all right this thing works on like
within 5 cm of okay so we just um uh
talked a bit about uh introductory um
items so let's look at binary research
the absolutely classic algorithm I call
it the Violet's Ice uh version which is
it I'm I'm I don't know about you but it
produce an emotional response in me so I
go to college and I see this first time
and I'm like I don't care about
dating this is going to be my
life I'm not kidding so I'm I'm looking
at this and I'm I'm thinking this is the
most beautiful thing I've seen in my
life The Violet is algorithm it's so
beautiful so symmetric so simple yet so
powerful it just I'm I'm not kidding my
hair is raised right now and I feel the
you know the hair in my back of my head
is like just weird so it's just an
algorithm that has its uh its own
Simplicity and beauty that is just
amazing it you know you can't like this
algorithm I have a 9 to5 job it's just
going to be go oh my goodness I'm going
to lose going to lose sleep over
it the way it works is obviously I'm
going to uh start take two iterators and
I'm going to take a value to be searched
and my attempt again is to collapse the
range the search range as much as
possible so with each step I'm going to
do well let me take the median point I
assume the range is searched and I'm
going to go to B plus C minus B by two
which is the the you know the damn
straight middle of the range I'm going
to look at that element and if I fall on
the left if I fall on the right I'm
going to throw away one half of the
search space
and that's the power of the algorithm
I'm going to reduce the the set of uh
things I'm looking at in half every time
and in the happy case when it's not
neither smaller nor greater than um the
median is not neither small not greater
than the the sord value I'm going to
know that I I'm right there and I return
true early because I I found it and
that's binary
search
okay so that that's actually a very nice
thing and U I invite you to think about
for example things like how often do I
get all the way to the end of the binary
search and the answer is actually in
half of the cases in half of the cases
I'm going to have to collapse the search
range all the way to one until I make a
decision simply because the way the
binary division works for example all
odd elements I'm going to look at them
in the last step so even though I do
return early it turns out a very often I
need to uh collapse the range all the
way to the bottom before making a
decision and after the range has
collapsed entirely I'm going to decide
that I did not find this uh this element
I'm going to just return false and be on
my way
right now if you look at uh if you crack
up on your standard Library
implementation and look for there is an
algorithm called STD binary search which
has the signature and you know let's
take a look at the STL implementation
does it look like this or not do you
think it's going to look like
this okay one nod negative not one hand
up okay why do you think it looks
different because C++ makes everything
more
complicated all right so first of all
like it has a lot of double underscores
there's going to be a lot of double
underscores in the whole thing right and
then there's going to be a lot of uh
just aggravation for uh for a variety of
reasons some of which I agree with some
of which enrage me but let's pass on
right let's go over that but actually
there is an algorithmic reason for which
the STL implementation is different
which is the following take a look at
the following let me go back one slide
here and show you the
following each pass through the loop I'm
going to do two comparisons V less than
star M and star M less than V so that's
two comparisons per pass it turns out if
you compare things like integers or
pointers those two can be actually one
comparison because uh I'm not sure about
your assembler knowledge which mine is
terrible but I do remember uh vaguely
that you you do a compare and then you
have it says Flags it's greater it's
smaller is whatever so you do one
compare and then two jumps so you
compare once and then you do two jumps
right that's not gener enough you know
for for example if you compare strings
it's not going to work just as nice
right so in the Ste they said hey you
know what um we're going to take a
predicate here so I'm going to use this
p and less is the name of my predicate
which is like a function that compares
to things and it has the semantics of
less than right so let me instead of uh
instead of saying uh that less than that
I'm going to call this function less
against the two values and I'm going to
make decisions based on that now the STL
wants to minimize the number of calls to
less and now you can see that this
previous algorithm the Viti has a
disadvantage right it calls less two
times per
iteration and that's kind of even though
in some situations in some cases it you
know just do one comparison it turns out
that STL wants to minimize calls to less
and therefore it goes to it uses a
different algorithm this this is a
slightly different algorithm it does not
have violet eyes it's not as uh
symmetric and beautiful as the other but
I like it
nevertheless um and the way it works is
again it cuts the range to be searching
in two so B plus C minus B by two and
then it makes the following decision if
the median is less than the value then
I'm going to advance the beginning
pointer all the way past the median
because I know that it it's impossible
that I'm what I'm looking for is going
to be on on that side right otherwise
I'm going to set the end to the median
because I know that there's nothing
interesting on that side of the median
and then I'm going to continue with the
new begin and
end right the point here is that I call
less only once per iteration but I don't
have an early return so I always go log
and steps all the way to
collapse of the range not of
civilization okay so I go all the way
until B becomes equal to e and then I
make my decision did I find the guy or
did I not find the guy and the decision
when whether I found or not is well did
I go all the way past the you know the
whole um the whole range
and I know already that
um uh star B is going to be uh V is not
going to sorry star B is not going to be
less than V and now I got to check the
other side of the test which is um uh V
less than and star B so I checked one
one way I checked the other way in the
previous algorithm I did it every
iteration right so I did two test is
that less is that greater and whatever
but in the second case I do only one
less in the in the loop and at the end I
do one more less and it turns out that
if you count the number of calls to less
this is
better so therefore this is an a
standard library with the appropriate uh
you know double underscores and all the
good stuff right awesome
so uh actually this is called Lower
bound because lower bound is a more
useful qu a more useful function than
just binary search because it gives me
information binary search says found it
like a Boolean right gives you a Boolean
found it oh no it's not there right but
actually if I want to insert if I want
to do something if I want to look for an
approximate value if I want to insert a
new valuing the thing if I want to know
the approximate position of where would
that guy would fit I would need more
information and that's where lower Bond
comes into play because it Returns the
position to the left of which everything
is strictly less
than so it gives you I'm looking for you
know I'm looking for 42 within like a
number of integers and it returns me the
position that I know for sure to the
left of that position everything is less
than 42 41 or less right and this
algorithm is uh very much like the other
one in fact the implementation in the
STL just calls lower bound and then has
one more line so literally is two lines
right so lower bind is going to again do
the the same uh strategy all over again
and uh this is the algorithm that is the
most informative um and then we have
upper bound which is everything to the
right of the upper bound is strictly
greater than my
value right so I have like I can search
you know I can SE give me give me the
position at which I know there's uh
everything here is smaller and then I
can give me the position such that
everything here is greater and then
there's what's in
between equal range in between
everything is equal to your value
searched because there could be
duplicates right and it turns out that
there's a third there's a fourth
algorithm called called STD equal
range which gives you that exact range
of equal values within the searched
range okay now the thing with equal
range is kind of funny because you could
say why do I need equal range I could
compute lower bound and then compute
upper bound and be done with it it turns
out that there's more to the story you
can Implement a more efficient equal
range if you search for both
simultaneously okay we're going to get
there fear not okay so let me get to 5
cm of this thing okay it does work so to
evaluate the you know how good you know
how well am I doing how good am I at
searching things we got to this uh we
got to discuss the expected number of
comparisons so um apologies for the bit
of math
here but the expected number of
something you sum or take the interal of
continuous but you sum in our case the
number of comparisons with the
probability of of that
event like okay if I have an array of u
10 values I search for the first I count
the number of comparisons the
probability is one by 10 assuming you
know I'm searching for all 10 I'm
looking for a second I count comparisons
what the probability I multiply with the
probability Etc if all are probably
equal then all probabilities are going
to be the same which is 1 byn so the
prob ities are kind of you know we can
simplify at least in first approximation
we can think all searches are equally
probable
right so uh that's what we're going to
use as our Benchmark the expected number
of
comparisons fine
now the question is how we design a fair
experiment because some searches are
going to succeed and some searches are
going to fail how many are going to
succeed and how many are going to fail
right what do you think would be a fair
I'm going to go back so you don't read
the slide how many uh how many searches
do you think would be a fair assessment
of binary search I have n elements to be
searched a fair assessment of the
average number of comparisons per
search all right any ideas do I search
for all the values in the in the
set do I ignore a few values yes please
sorry
three three
searches okay what would be the three
searched in the
middle oh no no I'm I'm testing now so
I'm testing I'm saying I want to count
how many average comparisons yeah it's
it's not the algorithm per se but it's
the experimentation with the algorithm
we're looking at so restating the
question I have n elements to search in
a set and I want to say how good do I
have a binary search algorithm and then
I say I'm going to design an
experiment uh am I liable equally
probably to search for every element in
the set would you
agree yes thank you thank you so I have
n searches that are going to be all
successful for each of the elements
right but then I'm going to have
unsuccessful uccessful
searches how many is for a good
experiment how many unsuccessful
searches should I have In a
well-designed
experiment okay information Theory what
is the most information you can extract
from a binary event one bit how do you
extract one bit from something that is
probably with 50% One Way 50% the other
way so if you want to design a good
binary search experiment you're going to
have as many failed searches as
successful searches that way extract
maximum information from binary search
you get one bit of information if you
don't get if you have more successful
searches than unsuc successful that
would mean you're biased toward the
success otherwise you're bi toward the
failure you don't you don't extract one
bit of information so the the absolute
um immutable truth we're looking at here
I'm going to have end successful
searches to experiment with and equally
and unsuccessful searches that I'm going
to be looking
at so far so good but now I ask you a
different
question which
is 5
cm which is you know I'm kind of
obstinate in using this thing because I
think it's cool but it's kind of the
range is terrible right and it's charge
and everything so I ask you a second
question of the fail searches how many
cases do I
have of distinct failed
searches so I may search for something
that's somewhere in the in between in
the wrong place right so I have like in
the AR I have like number 42 and number
46 and I happen to search for like 45
and it's it falls in between the interes
right and I have the case in which it's
all the way too small or all the way too
big right so I have three cases too
small too big somewhere in
between right and one you know other
question would be okay so I have like n
failed searches how many of these are
going to fall too small how many of them
are going to be too big and how many of
them are going to be just in
between so this is kind of you know this
is where I
protest because uh you know this is kind
of an important disc distinction that we
should make about binary searches like
you know how do we handle those
unsuccessful searches so let's look a
bit at the Distribution on an example so
I have this sorted array from 188 all
the way to 705 and I have a number of
searches with colored shapes up there
and of those I'm going to have um the
green ones are matches so I'm searching
for the exact thing the red squares are
going to be failur in between so they're
going to be equally probably in between
every two elements and then I'm going to
have a few triangles that are a bit kind
of out there because they are they fall
outside the whole the entire search
bound and those are the things that make
me
unhappy
right so we're going to have 50%
successful searches as we discussed
three failure cases search for Value in
between U the existing values search
value smaller than the minimum 188 and
search value larger than the maximum uh
which would be a 705
right now the traditional experimental
analysis that you're going to see in all
Theory books is going to have I'm going
to ascribe equal likelihood in between
or too small or too large meaning there
is only one triangle here and one
triangle
there and it makes the math easy it
makes researchers happy and it makes
practitioners
unhappy why am am I unhappy
because it turns out that very often we
do search for out of bonds value is
something that theoreticians don't you
know
ignore and um actually this whole uh you
know this whole idea started from
looking at uh you know in an application
at Nvidia I was looking at the failed
the searches in a binary search I was
like a lot of these go outside the bonds
and those are the worst case I mean come
on there's got to be something there
right uh let me give you a few examples
of uh cases in which we do search for
outof bounds values with some frequency
the stor values in the array are grouped
but the search values are scattered for
example we have theoretical measurements
versus actual measurements actual
measurements are always going to have
outliers that fall way outside the
bounds that's one case um you know in a
practical application in stock market
options you compute something in theory
and then you look at the actual
expirations and strike prices and again
you make may very easily fall out of
bonds just because it's not it's not a
fit for for whatever you're uh you're
theorizing um a I have a special list of
things like reserved allocated assigned
IP addresses and I want to search my IP
address whatever IP address I'm browsing
to with a list of a small list of
reserved values and it's very likely
that my values which are like 169
whatever whatever whatever are going to
either to the left or to the right of
what I'm searching
always when the search set is small I'm
going to uh experiment this out of bound
search simply because there's a lot of
likelihood that there a lot of sets a
lot of values outside the the search
range so uh we of course we still care
about speed even if a search set is
small because we may search these uh
small sets very very very very many
times so you know I'm not U you know I
don't care that it's small I still care
about saving a few comparisons there
right
right um special values in a list of
integrals words searching for pointers
in Array of allocations so um actually
binary search is used in a number of
allocators uh did this allocator
allocate this particular pointer and if
I have this uh you know pre-allocated
pointers sitting in an array and then I
come with a wild pointer from a
different allocator whatever and it's
going to be outside the bounds
guaranteed right um even for uh data
that is gaussian distributed don't
forget that are uh there's a
uh there's a 32% choice I my search data
is outside one standard deviation and 5%
that's it's outside two standard
deviations so if I select my data from a
gaussian distribution if it's grouped
enough I'm going to still have a lot of
searches outside the the search range um
many of the fat tail distribution so
this has been all you know there's been
a lot of talk about like the fat tail
and you know the heavy tail all of these
is long tail of Internet Commerce and
all that stuff and they show
distributions that fall like instead of
falling exponentially like that they
kind of fall and they kind of you know
the the density here at the tail is
quite High the density of probability so
I'm liable in this distributions to
search a lot of things that are outside
the natural
range so this is the this is the point
of contention I will argue that there
are quite a few more times I'm going to
search for things outside the the range
stored in the
array then uh the theory dictates the
theory says you can search one value out
of on the left one value on the right so
you have like two cases that's it you're
done everything else is in between and I
very much
disagree now uh this would be that what
the theory has as I told you there's one
triangle on the left one triangle on the
right everything else is in between the
square the red squares and then I have
the the the green squares which are the
successful searches so that's my
experiment
right the proof of binary search
optimality is done on this
case and I argue that this case is not
entirely
realistic I am more liable to have
values in the triangle area than
inside okay so now let's go
to my extreme situation which is
everything is out everything that fails
is outside the bounds like everything I
look for is going to is there's nothing
in between and this is like everything
that fails is going to be either way to
the left or way to the
right this is a artificial example but
let's design an algorithm that would
work well for that case how would you
design a binary search for this
case yes
please store the Min and Max I mean you
can you can look at begin n minus one
yes
who
agrees who
disagrees all right so let's remember
the very thank you very much let's
remember the very purpose of binary
search
eliminate as many candidates from each
comparison as possible if I look at the
extreme left how many candidates am I
going to
eliminate the red triangle on the
left which is n by two because I like n
failed n successful n by2 and n
by2 how can I but also like I don't
eliminate any of the potential
successful searches the green bullets
how do you draw a vertical line that is
going to eliminate as many bullets sorry
as many shapes green or red from this
image as possible if as was suggested
you're going to you're going to draw
here or let's say the beginning right if
you're going to draw here you can get
rid of these guys right but these guys
are still going to still look at
them so eliminate out of two n
possibilities you eliminate n by two can
I eliminate
more what if I go
here in the very
middle in the middle I have two
advantages number one I'm going to
eliminate half of the whole thing green
and red they're all gone so the first
shot is always best in the middle
because you get rid of literally half
the elements so if you search for two n
elements you're going to get rid of N
and number two the next step you know if
you want to look at the right bound or
the left bound you don't need to look at
both sorry I pressed this by mistake
okay so this is the key first shot in
any binary search you cut down the
goddamn middle if you remember one thing
about binary search from the stock First
Step you always cut in half it's like
pizza you just you know you want to just
cut in half and then think about the
rest that's your planning okay because
if you cut in half you're guaranteed to
eliminate half of the
uncertainty right and then Second Step
am I on the left oh let me look at this
guy am I on the right let me look at
this guy and you eliminate another n by
too and that's how the cookie crumbles
so for this extreme case it turns out
that the best algorithm
is cut in
half get rid of half the pi and then
look at the extreme that's
left and that's how you eliminate and
then continue with the standard you know
the the classic binary search so that
would be the optimal algorithm for this
case remember it's an artificial case
we're not this is not the final
algorithm right but it gives us thought
about wait a second uh maybe at least in
a few cases the standard binary search
is not what we're looking for it's not
our best
tool okay so for this extreme
case
um okay so I we just discussed all this
so the optimal algorithm is will be to
we just we just discussed all this it
was all in talk um just let me uh just
let me calculate real quick what would
be the um probability of us doing well
if I actually use the classic algorithm
it turns out that the second step is
wrong because I'm going to eliminate
only 3 n by8 elements instead of n by
two so that's quite uh problematic so we
don't want that we want the uh algorithm
as
follows in blue I show the comparisons
so remember lower lower Bond extreme if
begin is end I'm done then I compute the
middle of the range the median and then
I'm going to compute less of median and
value if it's less than then I'm going
to go to the upper half so the median is
less than the value so I'm going to go
to the upper half and then I'm going to
look at the very last element less last
value and then I I I can ear I can do an
early return and I'm
done otherwise I go to the lower half
right and in that case I'm going to
compare value against star begin with
which is the first
element and after all of the these two
steps have been uh completed I'm going
to proceed with the classic low lower
Bond because I know the bonds and I'm
essentially it's optimal right so
optimal algorithm for this extreme case
all failed searches are way outside the
bounds cutting
half get rid of half look at the first
element or the last element get rid of
half more and then continue with the
classic okay
but that's I you know that's not the way
it happens in the real world in the real
world you're going to have some outside
and some inside so let's look at the
actual best way to go
about a binary search that works in all
cases um actually uh there was a
question from the audience which was if
I know that I'm liable to search out of
bonds can't I just look at the beginning
end or the end and the answer is that
would be a sub optimal the thing is if
you cut in half then you only need to do
one more test if you look at the bonds
you need to do two
tests two is greater than
one
QED okay this laughter almost brought
down the house folks I mean come on keep
it down keep it low okay you're going to
bother people in the other rooms so you
don't want to look at the lower or upper
bound first you want to look in the
middle and then you eliminate half of
the cases and then you look only at one
one so by definition you're doing better
right
awesome so let's uh see the tradeoff
where it falls so remember the you know
the one extreme case would be I'm going
to have essentially nothing outside the
search bounds and in the other case I'm
going to have everything outside the
sege B so what would be the tradeoff
here in the classic algorithm I'm I'm
going to cut that half first and one
quarter next in the in case 2 which was
the artificial case we just discussed I
have very many out of B searches I'm
going to cut at 1 by two first and then
zero distance from the bound
next so okay you are an engineer so we
at 1 by two and one by4 versus 1 by two
and zero so okay so uh you know in one
extreme case I'm going to cut in half
like 1 by two 0.5 in the other case I'm
going to cut at zero which is like 0 by
five or whatever right so it's either
zero or
1x4 what is straight in the middle of
zero and
1x4 one by eight thank you very
much Norwegians are good at
math okay so I'm if I got you to chuckle
a bit I'm amazed that's fantastic okay
so ex so it's an engineering decision
but it's a principal decision it's not
an arbitrary decision in one extreme I
choose to cut at zero in the other case
I choose to cut at
1/4 and I have no idea no prior idea
about the distribution of actual
searches so I you know I got to choose
something in between these extremes what
can you choose as an engineer that is
the best between two extremes you're
going to choose the half you're going to
CH cut at one by eight so instead you
know it's like a binary search instead
of cutting at half all the time you're
going to start by by cutting at one
fourth
right so this is the idea we have no no
idea how to do so we're going to cut at
1 by two and then 1 by8 from the first
BN which is one by one by4 of what's
left so instead of saying uh you know uh
size is begin minus n Whatever by two
we're going to do by four and work from
there so let's take a
look this would be uh called the bounds
leaning binary search bounds leaning it
means it's it's always going to lean
toward the bonds because you're cutting
instead of cutting in half you're
cutting somewhere closer to the bond and
half which is at 1/4 right so uh this is
the important
tidbit
um here so I made it a different color I
was a bit surprised do you do you
distinguish this color okay look a lot
better on my laptop I mean it's supposed
to be like red right okay so here I'm
going to be in the upper half so I cut a
34s of because you know obviously I'm
going to go 34s because it's one4 from
the end right so I'm going to go 3 * C
minus B by 4 and if I stay in the lower
half I'm going to cut at B plus C minus
B by
4 right as I promised so I'm going to my
search is going to diverge quickly
toward the bounce of the search and once
I decided that actually yeah I got found
something that's less than in that case
I break and I complete with the classic
lower bound which is going to be optimal
for what's
left so the way this
works is let's take a look at a
successful search so let's look for
394 so in the classic algorithm I'm
going to cut first at
498 and then I'm going to cut in half as
362 and then again in half at 4 412 and
finally I'm going to 4 fall to on 394 so
that's the classic algorithm in the with
the other other algorithm I'm going to
cut first the GU half at
498 but then I'm going to go a bit
lefter than ax5 I'm going to go all the
way to a of two 267 and then luckily I
found the value in only three
searches right so that's a that's a good
case there are cases in which we do a
one more comparison in the uh case of
searching for four 412 again we're going
to cut here in half and then we're going
to look at 362 and then we're going to
look at 412 and we found it in the with
the new algorithm we're going to go from
uh from 498 all the way to 267 again so
that's a bit too far so I'm I'm you know
kind of taking a risk by going away too
far from the search element and then I'm
going to do to more comparisons I found
it for unsuccessful
searches
again the classic algorithm also always
cuts in half and then it's going to go
to 6 32 and in three steps he found the
it found the the the mismatch and in the
other case I'm going to do one more
comparison now if we search for
something that's out of bounds I do
expect to do better than the classic
algorithm because I'm going to do I'm
going to go real quick from 498 all the
way to 214 and then I'm going to
essentially find that it's missing from
the uh from the array so outof bound
searches are always going to be better
with the new
algorithm all right so as as we
discussed a bit uh in the beginning
there's a another algorithm for binary
search which is equal range and this is
where things get really interesting and
this is the most exciting part actually
I save it for the end and it goes the
following way okay equal range find me
to iterator such that everything here
here is less than everything is greater
than and what's in between is the good
stuff and if there's no good stuff the
range will collapse to will be like zero
length range right so that's equal
range we are Engineers we already have
lower Bond and upper Bond so the
straightforward approach would be call
lower Bond coal upper Bond yay
right
but it turns out that today's
implementations do a bit differently
they start with the Viti algorithm that
we discussed in the very beginning and
they cut the range in half and they cut
the range in half until they find some
iterator inside the F sequence inside
the the equal range and then they use
lower bound and upper bound to F the
bounds can we do
better and to get the answer to that let
me ask you a
question okay let's say you have an
array of 1 million elements and let's
say let's say we search for equal range
of uh let's say it's integers between
like 1 and 1 billion and there's 1
million of them right now let's say we
search equal range for number um
5,055 all
right
question how many of those equal values
am I bound to find am I likely to
find I may find zero I may find one I
may find two how what's the most I can
find thank you 1 million so I can find
one or two or three or four values up
all the way to 1 million these are
possibilities so equal range could
return a range that is wide like zero
elements I could find zero sorry I
forgot about that so I could find zero
elements I could find one two all the
way to 1 million now let me ask you a
second question my
friends what is the likelihood of me
finding one 1 million equal values is it
the same as me finding 01
elements okay somebody left I'm not sure
why but I see a lot of nods to the
negative right it's like you know I'm
more you know if I have 1 million
elements I'm more likely to find a few
that are of the same value as opposed to
million however my friends these two
algorith the STL algorithm assumes
there's equal probability of finding one
or 1 million elements that are
equal in reality what happens is that
the you know there's a lower probability
of me finding more the more elements you
find the lower the probability if you
find one you have some probability if
you have two okay that's a lower
probability if you have like a 1,000
that's a much lower probability and so
on so usually in all all distributions
that I know of uh gaussian uh uniform uh
ZIP power law fat tail what whatever you
do you're going to see that the
probability of finding a bunch of equal
elements is a lot lower than the
probability of finding a few equal
elements right and actually equal range
is designed in a way
surprisingly to assume that I'm just as
likely to find a million elements as one
as zero as five as
500 so that's not
cool so we don't want to have equal
probabilities for these things because
in reality they never are most real
world data is not like that most
theoretical data is not like that like
most data you can find is not going to
be like that and I'm going to propose to
you two
solutions which is one is Galloping
search and one is left leaning upper
bound they have cool names right
Galloping search I mean there's what's
going on what did where did horses enter
the equation here like what what's with
the horses right and left leading what's
with the Communists right I mean come
on so um I'm going to show you one thing
about uh G oh damn I'm going to show you
Galloping search this is not my
preferred algorithm but I think it's a
good algorithm to know all computer
theories know it very well very many
people in the industry do not know it
well how many people heard about
Galloping search before today all right
the people in the back are always the
smartest yes thank you very much yes
Victor okay so just a few which makes my
point Galloping search is a very
interesting algorithm because it works
very well in certain situations it works
like binary search except it starts from
one
side and I'm looking at the next element
step
one and I don't find it it's like still
less then I'm starting to lose my
patience I make two steps I you know I
take a step of one and then I take a
step of two and if I still don't find it
I'm continue to lose my patience that's
the Gallow part I'm going to make four I
take a jump at four steps and
essentially I'm doubling my step with
every step of the search I'm doubling
the my um my gate right which is kind of
unfair to horses because horses don't do
exponentials very much right I mean come
on but you know it's a good s it's like
a horse that starts to gallop right so I
starting with one and then two and then
four and then eight and all the way
maybe at some point I'm going to
overshoot the goddamn range and I'm
going to be very unhappy but what I do
next I'm going to be okay so I overshot
so what's I'm going to continue
searching in the remaining range using
classic binary
search and that's what Galloping search
does so you start from one side you
continue with increasing gate until you
overshoot or you find the value and
you're good and the last uh the last
steps are you're going to take by using
classic binary search so that would be
the Galloping lower
bound and again there's an integer in
there that you can see that it you know
it's uh where's the promis thing this is
the thing step times equal two so you
always multiply the step by two uh in
searching for the thing however this
works best is optimal if you have an
exponentially decreasing likelihood of
equal range being larger and that's only
a subset of all distributions again I'm
an engineer I want to do the right
compromise what is the right compromise
communists
left lean left leaning upper bound so to
search for equal range I'm going to do
the classic lower bound sorry the
improved lower Bond first and then I'm
going to do a left leaning upper bond
which is which is the
following it looks like upper bound
except I cut at n by4 all the time why
do I cut n by4 because I want to be so I
got the lower bound and then I don't
want to search in the middle because
that would give equal Ood to everybody I
want to somewhere close to the left
bound so that's why it's left
leaning I'm leaning to the left I'm I'm
cutting at 1/4 instead of half so that
way I'm giving more chance to short
ranges of equal elements than to longer
ele uh uh ranges of equal elements so
the combination between lower
bound bounds leaning lower bound and
left leaning upper bound would be the
best for equal search uh for equal range
with that let's uh look at a couple of
experiments so here I have
the unhappiest case for the new
algorithm this is the happiest case for
the new
algorithm and as you see we engineered
the whole
thing carefully in the sense that we do
have a little loss this number of
comparisons up to 1 million elements as
I promised about 20 right is the
maximum we do have a small loss like
half a comparison on average for the
worst case for the new
algorithm but in the happy case we have
a very good drop in the number of
searches for the new
algorithm number of comparisons
right but this is unfair to the old
algorithm this is unfair to the new
algorithm so I combined the two and I
showed how about we have 75% in Bound
fail searches and uh 25% 12 12 12 5 and
125 on each side and in that case I
still have a significant gain of a
couple of comparisons per
search to
conclude the
sorry lower b lower bond this was lower
Bond equal range is more difficult to
kind of of experiment with because you
know you got to you got to do searches
for every number of of equal elements so
you can arrange your experiment any way
you want in some ways right so that was
lower bound or binary search or upper
bound so for lower bound upper bound
binary search first cut at half I hope
you remember this always first cutting
half and then you cut on one4 from the
extreme up until you you find something
Bond and then then you continue with the
classic for binary search you use uh SD
lower Bond for equal range you use lower
bound and then you use the Communist
upper bound
okay all principal choices no magic
constants no fudge factors no tricks
nothing happens in my sleeves all
numbers were chosen in a principled
manner I'm going to choose you know half
you know split the difference and kind
of write in the middle that kind of
stuff now there's a dark horse in this
that I wanted to share with
you which is I did this all with it's
not me CH GP PT this is a great breakup
line right it's not me it's j
GPT with J GPT I used uh essentially I
use it all all the way for all the steps
uh in in doing this research I've used
CH GPT I used it for average number of
comparisons I it did a lot of math for
me it generated a lot of code a lot of
experiments a lot of timings a lot of uh
bugs it actually did generate a few
bugs uh the plots were generated by ch
PM wfr Alpha and this Slide the slide's
title was suggested by
chpt oh again with the horses I mean
come on I didn't okay this is crazy and
for more thoughts Bon everybody and
please come to my next talk which is
going to be focused on exactly this
stuff after lunch get coffee thank you
very
much